This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字 TWO 点 percent，在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人身披铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力。你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底被颠覆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iheart radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are diving into a topic that it is pretty emotionally charged.
对我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是20多岁的心理学。今天我们要深入探讨一个情绪色彩相当浓厚的话题。
It's definitely one of those areas of psychology and just growing up and existence that definitely hits close to home for a lot of people, which is exactly why I think we're talking about it. And what we're unpacking today is the psychology of emotionally immature parents. What kind of people they are, what it means, what it looks like, how it impacts us, and most importantly, how we can really move forward from a place of grace instead of frustration and needing to change them and wanting them to be different people. Because as we will kind of illuminate through this episode, sometimes it's really, really difficult. This is obviously a very sensitive subject for many of us. I think we often grow up thinking our parents can do no wrong. But as we
这绝对是心理学、成长和生存中那些让许多人感同身受的领域之一，这也是为什么我认为我们正在讨论它的原因。而我们今天要解开的是情绪不成熟父母的心理学。他们是怎样的人，这意味着什么，它长什么样，它是如何影响我们的，最重要的是，我们如何才能真正从一种充满感激而不是沮丧、不再试图改变他们、不再渴望他们成为不同的人的心态出发，向前迈进。因为正如我们将通过这一集所阐明的，有时这真的、真的很困难。对于我们许多人来说，这显然是一个非常敏感的话题。我想我们常常在成长过程中认为我们的父母是不会犯错的。但是随着我们
gain, I guess, more independence, more knowledge, more self-awareness, cracks can really start to show. And that can be so unnerving to unpack, especially, because, you know, our parents are such prominent figures in our lives. Our survival is so based on them for so long, they are so important to us. So when we suddenly or slowly become aware of the ways in which they are flawed and the ways in which they have perhaps not showed up for us the way they needed to or should have been required to, it can be a bit of an epiphany aha moment followed by a real kind of crash and a real come down.
我想，我们获得了更多的独立性、更多的知识、更多的自我觉察，裂痕真的开始显现了。而剖析这些会让人感到非常不安，尤其是因为，你知道的，我们的父母在我们生命中是如此显赫的人物。我们的生存长期以来如此严重地依赖他们，他们对我们是如此重要。因此，当我们突然或慢慢地意识到他们是有缺陷的，以及他们可能没有以我们需要的方式或本应需要的方式来支持我们时，这可能会变成一种顿悟的“啊哈”时刻，随后伴随着真正的崩溃和现实的清醒。
You know, perhaps you have always sensed that something was off in your relationship with your parents. You know, maybe they were loving but only on their terms. Or they were very present physically, but very emotionally unavailable, or they confided in you too much. They leaned on you too heavily. They made you feel like you had to be the adult in the relationship. And at the age you are now, you're kind of realizing, wait, other people's parents weren't like that. And maybe this has done some long-term damage to me.
你知道，也许你一直隐约觉得你和父母的关系有点不对劲。你知道，也许他们很爱孩子，但前提是必须按他们的条件来。或者他们身体上陪伴得很到位，但在情感上却非常冷漠，或者他们向你倾诉太多。他们太过于依赖你。他们让你觉得自己必须成为这段关系中的成年人。而以你现在的年纪，你开始意识到，等等，别人的父母不是这样的。也许这对我造成了一些长期的伤害。
And if any of that rings true, this episode is especially for you. We're going to be exploring what emotional immaturity looks like, where it comes from psychologically, how it affects us in our 20s, and really importantly, how we can begin to heal, how we can break generational cycles. I also want to mention, I think it's important to say this isn't going to be like a parent bashing episode. I don't think that the right approach to this topic is blame. I don't think that's helpful. What it's really going to be is just an honest attempt to find clarity and to understand these kinds of people better and to understand why they are the way they are, not to give them permission to continue to be that person and to continue to affect and impact our
如果其中有任何一点触动了你，这一集就是专门为你准备的。我们将探讨情绪不成熟是什么样子的，它在心理上是从哪里来的，它如何在我们的20多岁时影响我们，以及非常重要的一点，我们如何开始疗愈，如何打破代际循环。我还想提一下，我认为有必要说明，这不会是一场痛骂父母的节目。我不认为对待这个话题的正确方法是责备。我认为这没有帮助。我们要做的其实只是真诚地试图寻找清晰度，更好地理解这类人，并理解他们为什么会是现在的样子，不是为了赋予他们继续成为那种人并继续影响和冲击我们的
lives, but so that we can really heal. This is about us. And, you know, it is going to be different for every person. There's some parts of this that you might not relate to, but I definitely hope that you can just feel a little bit less alone. This kind of emotional immaturity that we're going to discuss, it often flies under the radar because it doesn't always look like overt or obvious trauma. I know the word trauma really rings alarm bells, but these things, these experiences of being emotionally neglected
生活的许可，而是为了让我们能够真正疗愈。这是关于我们自己的。而且，你知道的，对每个人来说情况都会有所不同。其中有些部分你可能无法感同身受，但我绝对希望你能因此感到不那么孤单。我们将要讨论的这种情绪不成熟，通常不会引起注意，因为它看起来并不总是像那种公开的或明显的创伤。我知道“创伤”这个词真的会敲响警钟，但这些事情，这些被情感忽视的经历
or emotionally mistreated or even just psychologically confused, do shape us very, very deeply. So just understanding it is definitely the first step towards emotional freedom and opening yourself up to more fulfilling, nurturing relationships. So that is a lot of, words for me to basically just to say, I hope this episode helps you. I hope it's informative. We have so much psychology, so much research, so much just concepts and theories packed into this episode. So without further ado, let us talk about the psychology of emotionally immature parents.
或情感虐待，甚至是单纯的心理困惑，确实对我们产生了非常非常深远的影响。所以，理解它绝对是通往情感自由的第一步，能让你敞开心扉去建立更多满足的、滋养的关系。所以，我说了这么多废话，其实只是想说，我希望这一集对你有所帮助。我希望它能提供丰富的信息。这一集中包含了这么多的心理学知识、那么多的研究、那么多的概念和理论。所以，废话不多说，让我们来聊聊情绪不成熟父母的心理学吧。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world,
2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真正相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是字母 T-W-O-Persent，在 I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
法则一，绝不要惹农家女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女友们》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个高产的骗子。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, We pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以整天谈论可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important. year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出这里有一条红线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的
for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the suit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find
我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得
it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Let's start this episode with some very high-level information to kind of cover our bases. What do we really mean by emotionally immature parents? Because it does seem kind of subjective in a way.
在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 Learn the Hardway，立即收听。让我们以一些非常高级别的信息来开始这一集，以涵盖我们的基础。我们真正所说的“情绪不成熟的父母”是什么意思？因为在某种程度上，这似乎确实有点主观。
Well, the first thing you need to know is that this phrase was first popularized by Dr. Lindsay C. Gibson. She is a clinical psychologist, and if you have ever even dipped your toe into this space before, you will probably know of her book, Adult Children of Emotionally Immature Parents. It was released in 2015. It is like the Bible on this kind of thing. In this book, she basically introduces us to this idea of emotional. immaturity as a set of traits that includes things like poor empathy, volatility, self-centeredness, and a real ingrained avoidance of emotional responsibility. So what does this look like? This might look like parents who struggle to validate your emotions. So you've said you're anxious or you're frustrated or you're hurting and they said to calm down or they said that you are
嗯，你需要知道的第一件事是，这个短语最初是由琳茜·C·吉布森（Dr. Lindsay C. Gibson）博士推广的。她是一位临床心理学家，如果你曾经涉足过这个领域，你大概会知道她的书《成年子女：如何应对情绪不成熟的父母》（Adult Children of Emotionally Immature Parents）。它于2015年出版。这简直是这类事情的圣经。在这本书中，她基本上向我们介绍了情绪不成熟这一概念，它是一组特征，包括同理心差、情绪多变、以自我为中心，以及对情感责任根深蒂固的逃避。那么，这表现为什么呢？这可能表现为那些难以确认你情绪的父母。所以，当你表达自己感到焦虑、沮丧或受伤时，他们会叫你冷静下来，或者说你是
overreacting. Perhaps they took your requests or your feedback to personally. You know, you'd say, I don't like it when you do that. And they'd say, well, I guess I'm just a horrible mother. I guess I'm the worst parent alive. That's a way of them basically saying, what you have to say doesn't matter. You have to protect my feelings. Emotionally immature parents are also very uncomfortable with vulnerability. Kind of goes hand in hand with that last symptom. Often they may pretend to not hear you or understand you when you're sharing your feelings or they dismiss you. They say, can we talk about it later? They would maybe turn it back onto you or give you the silent treatment.
反应过度。也许他们把你的要求或反馈看得太个人化了。你知道的，你会说：“我不喜欢你那样做。”然后他们会说：“好吧，我想我只是个糟糕的母亲。我想我是活在世上最糟糕的父母。”这基本上是他们表达的一种方式，意思是：你要说的话并不重要。你必须保护我的感受。情绪不成熟的父母对脆弱也感到非常不自在。这与上一个症状密不可分。通常，当你分享自己的感受时，他们可能会假装听不见或听不懂，或者他们会打发你。他们会说：“我们以后再谈好吗？”他们可能会把话题转回到你身上，或者对你进行冷暴力。
Any kind of emotional openness or vulnerability is really swept under the rug. They expect you to manage their emotions. It's a very self-centered thing. They make demands of you. They ask you to essentially be there, just emotional witness, but they're psychologists, their counselor, their healer, their doctor, their marriage counselor, all these things that as a child, that's not your role, right? It's not your role to parent them. They are the adult. They are the ones who wanted you.
任何形式的情感开放或脆弱都被严严实实地扫到地毯底下。他们希望你来管理他们的情绪。这是一件非常以自我为中心的事情。他们对你提出要求。他们本质上要求你在那里，仅仅作为一个情感见证者，但他们是心理学家、他们的顾问、他们的治疗师、他们的医生、他们的婚姻顾问，所有这些事情，作为一个孩子，这不是你的角色，对吧？当他们的父母不是你的角色。他们是成年人。他们是想要你的人。
They are the ones who chose to have you. And so they need to be, you know, ready to step into the role of parent and understand that it's not the same as being friends. friends with your child. Being a parent and being a friend or being a counselor or being a partner, they're different things. And as the child, you cannot be all of them. That's something that they typically don't understand. It's very common when a parent will be like, oh yes, my daughter is like my best friend or my son is my best friend. And that's always code for you guys don't have emotional boundaries. Like they are oversharing, they're overstepping. Perhaps they're even complaining about your other parent. It can get very complex.
他们是选择生下你的人。所以他们需要，你知道的，准备好扮演父母的角色，并理解这与和你的孩子做朋友是不一样的。做父母和做朋友、做顾问或做伙伴是不同的事情。而作为孩子，你不可能兼顾所有这些。这是他们通常不理解的事情。当父母说“哦，是的，我女儿就像我最好的朋友”或“我儿子是我最好的朋友”时，这是非常普遍的。这总是代表着你们之间没有情感边界。比如他们过度分享，他们越界了。也许他们甚至在抱怨你的另一个父母。这可能会变得非常复杂。
They also have poor boundaries. That kind of goes hand in hand. They overshare. They expect loyalty at all cost. They feel threatened by your independence, which can sometimes mean that you stunt yourself and you hold yourself back to appease them. Essentially, they are the most important person in the relationship. The relationship between you two, you come second to their feelings,
他们的边界感也很差。这与前一点息息相关。他们过度分享。他们不惜一切代价地要求忠诚。他们对你的独立感到受到威胁，这有时意味着你会停滞不前，压抑自己去取悦他们。本质上，他们是这段关系中最重要的人。你们两个之间的关系，比起他们的感受、
their wants, their needs, their volatility, their, inability to express themselves. This may not seem overtly abusive or neglectful. And in many situations, people with emotionally immature parents will say, well, they were really physically present for me. They were affectionate. They would buy me things. We would do fun things. They were, all my needs were taking care of. But emotionally, it was a very different situation. So the kind of parenting that we are describing is not technically abusive, though I think that that definition is definitely very flexible at the moment. It's a kind of parenting called emotional neglect. The research really backs up how significant the impact of this can be. A 2017 study published
他们的欲望、他们的需求、他们的情绪多变、他们表达自己的无能，你都要排在第二位。这可能看起来并不明显是虐待或忽视。在许多情况下，拥有情绪不成熟父母的人会说：“嗯，他们在物质上确实陪伴了我很多。他们很慈爱。他们会给我买东西。我们会一起做有趣的事情。他们，我的所有需求都得到了照顾。”但在情感上，情况却大不相同。所以我们所描述的这种育儿方式在技术上不算虐待，尽管我认为这个定义目前肯定非常灵活。这是一种被称为情感忽视的育儿方式。研究确实证实了这种影响可能有多么重大。2017年发表的一项研究
in the Journal of Child Psychology and Psychiatry, it found that emotional neglect in childhood, especially when it's subtle or unspoken, is strongly correlated with an increased risk for anxiety, depression, and difficulties with emotional regulation in adulthood. You know, having this unpredictable emotional environment can make us feel like we're not allowed to express how we feel out of fear that our parents will be hurt or they will somehow turn it around on us. So there is an immediate defensiveness and a desire to protect ourselves in almost all interactions, which means that we emotionally suppress, we emotionally numb, we kind of lie to ourselves about what we're really feeling. And this can really take its toll on us. Emotions,
在《儿童心理学与精神病学杂志》上，研究发现，童年时期的情感忽视，尤其是当它是微妙的或未曾明言的时，与成年后焦虑、抑郁以及情绪调节困难风险的增加密切相关。你知道，拥有这种不可预测的情感环境会让我们觉得，由于害怕父母会受伤或者他们会以某种方式把矛头指向我们，我们是不被允许表达自己的感受的。因此，几乎在所有的互动中，都会有一种即时的防御性和保护自己的渴望，这意味着我们在情感上压抑，在情感上麻木，我们在真正感受到的事情上对自己撒谎。而这确实会让我们付出沉重的代价。情绪，
they are essential. They are really, really important things. Like, we don't just have emotions as decoration. They are our way of interacting with the world. And so if our relationship to them has been disrupted by a parent who has taught us how to handle or showed us how to handle emotions, the wrong way. That's going to lead to some long-term consequences. One thing, a lot of therapists or psychologists who handle individuals who have emotionally mature parents, they report a lot of their clients having something called alaxathemia, which is a difficulty in identifying and expressing emotions. And this makes sense. You know, when your emotional world is dismissed or ignored, you learn to disconnect from it. So what are the roots of this emotional
它们是至关重要的。它们是真正非常重要的东西。就像，我们拥有情绪不仅仅是为了装饰。它们是我们与世界互动的方式。因此，如果与它们的关系被一个教导我们如何处理情绪或以错误方式向我们展示如何处理情绪的父母所破坏，那将导致一些长期的后果。一件事是，许多处理情绪成熟父母个案的治疗师或心理学家报告说，他们的许多客户患有一种叫做“述情障碍”的病症，即难以识别和表达情绪。这是说得通的。你知道，当你的情感世界被忽视或忽略时，你就会学会与它断开连接。那么，这种情绪不成熟的根源是什么呢？
immaturity. Really what it stems from in our parents is unresolved childhood wounds that they themselves are carrying. It is an age old saying hurt people, hurt people. That's not just a saying. It often ends up being a real terrifying fact of life. If someone wasn't taught how to regulate their emotions, if they grew up in a home where feelings were ignored or invalidated, they're going to struggle to do that with themselves and eventually with their own children. And that makes lower sense, right? If you never learnt the tools, if it was never properly modeled for them, for your parents, it's so difficult for them to come walk into situations and be emotionally mature,
实际上，它在我们父母身上源于他们自己所承载的未解决的童年创伤。这是一句古老的俗语：受过伤害的人会伤害别人。这不仅仅是一句话。它往往最终成为生活中一个真正可怕的事实。如果一个人没有被教导如何调节自己的情绪，如果他们在一个感情被忽视或被否定的家庭中长大，他们在对待自己时就会举步维艰，最终在对待自己的孩子时也会如此。这完全说得通，对吧？如果你从未学过这些工具，如果你的父母从未为你正确示范过，他们要走进各种情境并表现得情绪成熟是极其困难的，
especially considering how much of our social learning is just purely observational. Here's the thing, we don't develop emotional maturity in isolation. It's not like we are born knowing how to regulate our feelings. We as well as our parents learn through a process called co-regulation. So when we're children, our parents are meant to help soothe us, explain what we're feeling, tell us that it's going to be okay, give us the environment to understand that emotions are not these big, scary things. That's how we learn how to do it ourselves.
尤其是考虑到我们的社会学习有多少纯粹是通过观察获得的。事情是这样的，我们不会在孤立中发展出情绪成熟度。我们并不是生来就知道如何调节自己的情绪的。我们和我们的父母一样，通过一个被称为“共调节”的过程来学习。因此，当我们还是孩子的时候，我们的父母应该帮助我们平静下来，解释我们的感受，告诉我们一切都会好起来的，为我们提供一个环境，让我们明白情绪不是什么大不了的、可怕的事情。这就是我们如何学会自己做到这一点的。
When your parent perhaps didn't have someone, you know, demonstrating that for them, well, they were kind of at a loss. Who was going to teach them, if not the most important person in their lives? And there's a very famous experiment from about the 70s that shows this beautifully. It's called the Stillface Experiment by Dr. Edward Tronick. And in the study, he really wanted to find out how we learned to regulate emotions. And so he had a mother and a child and he would have the mother play normally with her baby. Smile, coo, engage, giggle with them.
当你的父母可能没有一个人，你知道的，为你示范这一点时，好吧，他们可以说是束手无策了。如果不是他们生命中最重要的人，谁来教他们呢？关于这一点，有一个大约70年代的非常著名的实验，完美地展示了这一点。它被称为爱德华·特罗尼克（Dr. Edward Tronick）博士的“静止脸实验”（Stillface Experiment）。在这项研究中，他真正想要弄清楚我们是如何学会调节情绪的。于是他让一位母亲和孩子在一起，让母亲像往常一样和婴儿玩耍。微笑、逗弄、互动、和他们咯咯地笑，
and then the mother was asked to suddenly go expressionless, to not respond to her child. Her face went still, and within seconds the child would get distressed, would start trying to get her attention, wouldn't know how to regulate what they were feeling. It was a bit of an ethically murky study, but it gives you a clear visual of how much children rely on that emotional feedback from their parents.
然后要求母亲突然面无表情，对她的孩子不予理睬。她的脸变得静止，几秒钟内，孩子就会感到痛苦，开始试图引起她的注意，不知道该如何调节自己的感受。这是一个在伦理上有些模糊的研究，但它让你清晰地直观看到，孩子们多么依赖来自父母的情感反馈。
When it's missing, perhaps how it was missing for your parents, when there is no co-regulation, that stress can build fast and without knowing it, we internalize the message of, my feelings are dangerous, my feelings are too much, I don't have the framework or the environment to manage them, so I should just completely suppress them. That's where emotional immaturity comes from. And nowadays, we, this generation kind of has more of an understanding of why it is important to validate your children's emotions. We understand why things like boundaries are essential. We understand why, you know, suppressing your feelings has led to decades of, like, people ignoring mental health crises and
当这种反馈缺失时，也许就像你父母当年缺失的那样，当没有共调节时，压力就会迅速积聚，在不知不觉中，我们内化了这样一条信息：我的感受是危险的，我的感受太多了，我没有管理它们的框架或环境，所以我应该彻底压抑它们。这就是情绪不成熟的来源。如今，我们这一代人对为什么肯定孩子的感受很重要有了更多的理解。我们理解为什么像边界感这样的事情是必不可少的。我们理解为什么，你知道的，压抑自己的感受会导致数十年来人们忽视心理健康危机和
mental health issues. We're a generation that's a lot more open to it, but we're still managing with this previous generation who learnt from their parents, you know, sit up and shut up. Be seen and not heard. Essentially, the way I like to think about it is we are managing the the fallout of generations of emotional suppression, and we're managing that on an individual level and dealing with it on a micro level of just interacting with our parents. You know, they are the product of a whole long line of inadequate emotional training and availability. There's another explanation for our parents' emotional immaturity, and it's something called
心理健康问题。我们这一代人对这些更加开放，但我们仍在努力应付上一代人，他们从父母那里学到的是“坐好，闭嘴”。只许看，不许说。本质上，我喜欢把这看作是我们在处理几代人情感压抑的后果，我们在个体层面上处理这个问题，并在与父母互动的微观层面上应对它。你知道的，他们是整个漫长的不充分情感训练和情感可得性历史的产物。对于父母的情绪不成熟，还有另一种解释，叫做
developmental arrest. That sounds very dramatic. but it's actually really common. It's when someone's emotional growth kind of pauses, usually because of trauma, stress, or neglect in their own childhood. So when we go through trauma, especially during childhood or adolescence, it can actually physically interrupt our brain's natural development. The parts of our brain that are supposed to grow
发展停滞（developmental arrest）。听起来很戏剧化。但实际上非常普遍。当一个人的情感成长在某种程度上停滞时，通常是因为他们自己童年时期的创伤、压力或忽视。因此，当我们经历创伤时，尤其是在童年或青春期，它实际上可以物理性地中断我们大脑的自然发育。我们大脑中本该生长的部分
and support emotional regulation and connection and empathy that development gets sign-lined. Why? It's because survival in those situations is coming first. So imagine you have a parent who has experienced war, or who has seen a family member be incredibly abusive or who encountered a really traumatic loss or circumstances or poverty when they were younger.
并支持情绪调节、联系和同理心的发育被边缘化了。为什么？因为在这些情况下，生存是第一位的。所以想象一下，你有一个经历过战争的父母，或者看到过家庭成员极其虐待他人，或者在年轻时遭遇了真正的创伤性失落、环境或贫困。
When we are in those moments, our body goes okay. All we need to focus on is getting through this, is getting through this moment. And when it's over and when it's done, we can continue with some of the other things. We can continue with that neural pruning and that synaptic pruning. And we can continue with the evolving of our brain matter and these structures. But until the threat is passed, we just have to be focused on survival. That is developmental arrest. your parent may quite literally be frozen at the time that a particular trauma took place in their lives.
当我们处于那些时刻时，我们的身体会说：好的。我们唯一需要关注的是度过难关，度过这个时刻。当它结束了，完成了，我们可以继续做其他事情。我们可以继续进行神经修剪和突触修剪。我们可以继续发展我们的大脑物质和这些结构。但直到威胁过去，我们只能专注于生存。这就是发展停滞。你的父母可能字面意思上就被冻结在他们生命中发生特定创伤的那个时间点。
They never exited that survival zone. And so you're 25, you're 26, you may be even in your 30s or older, dealing with someone who's 50 or 60 who actually might be psychologically and emotionally, have the emotional age that's significantly younger than you. hence why, although they have the age, you have the maturity that allows you to almost, or forces you almost to have to parent them. Now, I give these explanations not as an excuse for our parents' behavior, but more as an explanation. I don't think they want to hurt you. They just never learn how to do it the right way themselves. In other words, it's not always about malicious intent.
他们从未离开过那个生存区。所以你25岁、26岁，甚至30多岁或更大，却在和一个50岁或60岁、在心理和情感上的年龄实际上明显比你小的人打交道。因此，尽管他们年龄比你大，但你拥有的成熟度几乎让你能够——或者几乎迫使你——不得不去抚育他们。现在，我给出这些解释不是为了给我们父母的行为找借口，而是作为一个解释。我不认为他们想伤害你。他们只是从未学会自己用正确的方式去做这件事。换句话说，这并不总是出于恶意的意图，
it's often about an emotional unavailability that has been passed down for generations that goes unexamined. Does it mean it hurts less? No. Does it mean that now you are being and will be forced to continue the cycle? Also no. You are currently listening to this episode. Do you think your parents would ever have this self-awareness to search something like this?
通常是因为代代相传、未经审视的情感疏离。这是否意味着痛苦会减少？不。这是否意味着你现在正在并将被迫继续这个循环？同样不。你目前正在收听这一集。你认为你的父母会有这种自我觉察去搜索这样的内容吗？
Do you think your parents are engaging in psychological, help or looking for self-help content or looking for instruction? No. And it's that conscious deliberateness of being like, I'm going to interrupt past learnings and I'm going to interrupt a pattern of generational trauma to divert this path and change the outcomes for myself that is so powerful and that means that you are not going to turn out like them. You are doing the work that should have been done decades and decades ago to reverse very deeply ingrained patterns of thinking and patterns of emotionally relating to others that are not going to be passed on from here or now.
你认为你的父母会参与心理援助、寻找自助内容或寻找指导吗？不会。正是这种有意识的决心，即“我要打断过去的学习，我要打断代际创伤的模式，来改变这条道路，为我自己改变结果”，它是如此强大，这意味着你不会变得和他们一样。你正在做本该在几十年前就完成的工作，以扭转那些根深蒂固的思维模式和与他人建立情感联系的模式，这些模式将从此时此地起不再传递下去。
So we are going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to explore what the impact may have been on you so far. I want to validate that that is totally normal. And also how you can heal, how you can set boundaries, how can you accept that you can't change them, but also encourage yourself to change within you and to undo some of this past neglect. Stay with us, all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
所以我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想探讨这到目前为止对你可能产生了什么影响。我想确认这完全是正常的。以及你如何能够疗愈、如何设定边界、如何接受你无法改变他们，但同时也鼓励自己在内心做出改变，并消除过去的一些忽视。留下来，这一切以及更多内容就在这段简短的休息之后。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真正相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是字母 T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，在 I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
法则一，绝不要惹农家女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女友们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个高产的骗子。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
在 Iheart radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point,
每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以整天谈论可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，
this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important
到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出这里有一条红线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的
year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app search learn the hard way and listen now the big question that a lot of us have is how does this show up in our lives first and foremost one of the biggest ways that emotionally immature
而我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 Learn the Hardway，立即收听。我们许多人都有的一个大问题是，这如何在我们的生活中表现出来？首先，情绪不成熟的
parenting shows up for us in adulthood is through our attachment style now if you are someone who has ever found themselves spiraling after someone didn't text you back or you feel the urge to emotionally shut down the moment someone gets too close, you are not alone. These responses don't just come out of nowhere. There's been so much research that has shown that emotional validation that is missing during childhood is strongly linked to developing an anxious or avoidant attachment style in adulthood. That's the first thing that you may be noticing, especially as we begin to date and we begin to want to have serious relationships or serious long-lasting friendships,
育儿方式在成年后表现出来的一个最大方式是通过我们的依恋风格。现在，如果有人发现自己在别人没有回短信时陷入精神崩溃，或者在别人靠得太近时有一种想要在情感上关闭自我的冲动，你并不孤单。这些反应并不是凭空出现的。已经有太多的研究表明，童年时期缺失的情感确认与成年后发展出焦虑型或回避型依恋风格密切相关。这是你可能会注意到的第一件事，特别是当我们开始约会、想要建立严肃的关系或严肃持久的友谊时，
you find that your way of relating to other people has a whole other dimension to it compared to your friends or other people that you know. And you can't quite figure out why. You can't remember consciously wanting to be this way. Often it's the remnants of this emotional upbringing that you had. Then there's this other experience that is somewhat common and it's feeling as if it's your job to hold everything together, to be the emotionally mature one,
你会发现你与他人建立联系的方式与你的朋友或其他你认识的人相比，有着完全不同的维度。而你却说不清为什么。你不记得自己曾有意识地想要变成这样。通常，这是你所经历的那种情感育儿方式的残余。然后还有另一种比较常见的体验，那就是觉得把一切都维系在一起是你的工作，做那个情绪成熟的人，
to be the one that people come to, and feeling like there is so much guilt to be in control of your emotions and to be mature for your age. Mature for your age, I absolutely despise this term. Anytime someone says they're very mature for their age, I always think, well, that's a trauma response. It is, it literally is a trauma response.
做那个别人来找的人，并觉得为了控制自己的情绪、为了表现得比实际年龄成熟而背负了那么多的负罪感。“比实际年龄成熟”，我绝对痛恨这个词。每当有人说某人比实际年龄成熟时，我总是想：好吧，那是一种创伤反应。确实如此，它字面意思上就是一种创伤反应。
It's called fawning, actually, by this trauma expert. His name is Pete Walker. And he found that the typical way that people think of us responding to danger through fight, flight, and freeze isn't the entire picture. There's also this fourth FF called fawning, where you essentially put everyone's needs first because it feels safer that way. And it really involves constantly appeasing others to avoid conflict, making friends with the threat, being the one that people need to rely on emotionally so that you're never the one on the outside. In childhood, this may have looked like staying quiet to avoid upsetting your parents or mediating arguments.
这种现象实际上被称为“迎合”，由一位名叫皮特·沃ーカー的创伤专家提出。他发现，人们通常认为我们面对危险时的反应是战斗、逃跑和僵住，但这并不全面。还有第四种“F”，叫做迎合，即你基本上把所有人的需求放在首位，因为那样感觉更安全。这确实包括不断安抚他人以避免冲突、与威胁化敌为友、成为人们在情感上需要依赖的人，这样你就永远不会成为局外人。在童年时期，这可能表现为保持安静以免惹父母生气，或是充当争吵时的调解人。
In adulthood, it looks like people pleasing, avoiding confrontation, putting everyone else's needs before your own, making excuses for people. giving them a million second chances, even when it's costing you. Because when you were growing up, the emotional temperature of your household depended on your ability to sue the parent, your ability to avoid triggering their anger, your ability to anticipate their moods. Here's the paradox, though. Emotionally immature parents often raise incredibly emotionally aware children. And that's not because they modeled that.
到了成年，它表现为取悦他人、逃避对抗、把所有其他人的需求置于你自己的需求之前、为别人找借口，给他们一百万次重来的机会，即使这会让你付出代价。因为在你成长过程中，你家庭的情感温度取决于你安抚父母的能力、你避免触发他们怒火的能力、你预测他们情绪的能力。然而，这里存在一个悖论。情感不成熟的父母往往会抚养出极其具有情感意识的孩子。这并不是因为他们模范地展现了这种成熟度，而是因为你为了生存不得不变成那样。你知道，你不得不逼自己过早成熟。你不得不学会自我调节。你不得不预测他人的反应以变得独立，甚至到了近乎过分的程度。这创造了一种非常具体的情感状况，被称为“过度韧性”或“过度独立”。这非常有趣，因为一些有情感不成熟父母的人，如果他们没有意识到这一点，最终自己也会变得情感不成熟。而另一些人则最终变成了这种状态，变得非常过度独立。我真的很想知道这背后的研究是什么。我其实找不到太多的解释。有些人说，这是因为家庭之外存在其他支持网络。有些人说，这与出生顺序有很大关系。但如果你属于第二类过度独立的人，你会发现你依靠自己的能力对你来说是一种资产。它就像一个情感安全网。你的独立感觉是你最大的慰藉。在许多方面，它确实是一种资产。能够挑战自我、依靠自己、能够走出去争取你想要的东西是一件好事。但独立的另一面是，当你真正需要帮助时，你可能会发现很难开口。你可能会发现很难依靠他人，因为你已经内化了一种信念，即依赖别人是不安全的。你可能会对自己设定高得不可能达到的标准，总是需要保持高效，总是需要成为人们依赖的那个人，渴望成为一个极其省心的人。
maturity, but because you had to become that way to survive. You know, you had to grow up too fast. You had to learn to self-regulate. You had to predict other people's reactions to become independent, almost to a fault. This creates this very specific emotional condition called hyper-resilience or hyper-independence. And it's very interesting because some people with emotionally immature parents, if they're not aware of it, just end up, becoming emotionally immature themselves. Other people end up becoming this kind of way, very hyper-independent. And I really want to know what the research is behind. I couldn't really find much of an explanation. Some people say it's the existence of other support networks outside of the family. Some people say it has a lot to do with birth order. But if you are in the second category of people who are hyper-independent, what you will find is that your ability to own the birth order. rely on yourself feels like an asset to you. It is like an emotional safety net. Your independence feels like your greatest comfort. And in many ways it is an asset. Being able to challenge
如果我这么说，请让我握着你的手。比如，你可能一直在试图通过自己的行动来赢得爱。那个内在的声音说“只有当你有用且不成为太大负担时，你才是可爱的”，这通常源于这些早期的互动。这也是第二部分所说的，嗯，我渴望情感安全，如果别人不能为我创造，我就自己为自己创造。最后，许多人在成年后报告说，他们在情感不成熟的父母环境中长大，经历着一种叫做“情感孤独”的现象。这个概念最近在依恋创伤的研究中被越来越多地讨论，因为让人感到孤独的不仅仅是身体上的隔离。你可以有很多很多朋友，不断被人群包围，却感到在情感上深深地不被看见。棘手的是，这种孤独感看起来并不像我们通常所期望的那样。有时它看起来像是过得很好，是被人群包围的那个人、是解决问题的人、拥有令人惊叹的朋友圈，但到了最后，你回到家，内心深处有一种强烈的渴望，希望能被照顾，但同时又无法向其他人敞开心扉。直到有人真正第一次看到你，你可能甚至没有意识到自己有多么情感孤独，这可能会让人感到非常严重的不适或陌生。所以那个心理学家林赛·吉布森，我们之前提到过她的工作，她将情感孤独称为情感不成熟父母的成年子女的一个决定性创伤。这不是缺少人陪伴，而是缺少被了解。
yourself, rely on yourself, being able to go out and ask what you want is a great thing. But the flip side of being independent is that you might find it hard to ask for help when you really need it. You may find it hard to lean on people because you've internalized the belief that that depending on someone else isn't safe. You may hold yourself to impossibly high standards, always needing to be productive, always needing to be the one that people rely on, wanting to be super low maintenance.
你可以完全看出这在你的二十多岁时会带来多么深刻的冲击。这是一个我们真正开始摸索成年人际关系的时期，通常是第一次在没有家人陪伴在身边的情境下。因此，旧的动态开始重新上演。浪漫关系可能最终会反映出你与父母相处时的不一致。你可能会选择情感上不可用的伴侣。你可能会发现你自己也是情感上不可用的。你把别人推开。
And I'm going to hold your hand when I say this. Like, it might be that you are trying to earn love through your actions. The inner voice that says, you're only lovable if you're useful and not too much of a burden, that often comes from these early dynamics. It's also that second part of saying,
你们开始不必要的争吵，甚至不知道原因何在。原因在于，一直以来，你根本不理解被看见意味着什么。因此，被某人看见会让你感到非常具有威胁性。因为你的父母就像是：你不想被看见。这对我们很好。让我们来被看见。我们会占领所有的空间。我们会占领房间里的所有氧气。
well, I crave emotional safety and if someone else can't create it for me, I'll create it for myself. Here is the final thing that a lot of people report experiencing as adults as they grew up in an emotionally immature parental environment. It's something called emotional loneliness. This concept is being talked about a lot more in research on attachment trauma recently because it's not just physical isolation that makes people feel lonely. You could have a lot more. so many friends and be constantly surrounded by people but feel deeply emotionally unseen and the tricky part is that this kind of loneliness doesn't look how we would typically expect it to look sometimes it looks like being fine
你可以只坐在角落里，不要小题大作，不要发出声音，而我们则向你倾泻侮辱，向你抛出问题，或者让我们让你如履薄冰。所以，当你成为成年人，而你发现：哈，人们居然期待我谈论自己的情感。人们居然想了解关于我的事情。这会让人感到非常不安。精神分析学家埃里克·埃里克森，他实际上描述了人生的这个阶段。这被称为“亲密与孤立”的阶段。我们每个人都确实会经历它。但那些拥有情感不成熟父母或早期关系的人会发现，这要困难得多，因为他们对爱、亲密感和信任的蓝图是由一个根本不理解这些事情的人塑造的。所以是的，每个人都会为此挣扎，关系也很艰难，但这就像是你正踏入亲密关系，你觉得自己已经准备好了，然后你意识到你正试图在不平整的地基上建造一栋房子。你知道的，
being the one who is surrounded by people being the fixer having the amazing friendship group but at the end of the day you kind of come home and you have this deep craving to be cared for as well but also an inability to open the door to other people. You might not even realize until someone really sees you for the first time how emotionally lonely you have been and it can be very seriously uncomfortable or foreign. So that psychologist, Lindsay Gibson, whose work we mentioned earlier, she talks about emotional loneliness as a defining wound for adult children of emotionally immature parents. It is not the absence of people, it is the absence of being known.
其他所有人都在建造他们的房子，那是一个完美的生产线，而你却在想：等等，我不知道木头是腐烂的，我不知道结构是不稳固的，我需要去做所有这些额外的功课，而其他人却过得很轻松。说实话，这真的会让人感到非常沮丧，因为你渴望亲密，但你又同时对它感到恐惧，或者在它有机会拒绝你之前就拒绝了它。通常正是在这个阶段，我们开始意识到：嘿，也许我早期的环境并不是它本该有的样子。而真正的问题在于，痛苦来自于我们试图自己填补这些空白，我们试图寻找理由来解释父母的行为，或者通过说一些话来淡化我们有时觉得有多么困难，
And you can totally see how this might hit hard in your 20s. This is a time when we're really navigating adult relationships, often for the first time without our families right beside us. And so the old dynamics start to play out again. Romantic relationships may end up mirroring the inconsistency you experienced with a parent. You might choose emotionally unavailable partners. You might find that you yourself are emotionally unavailable. You push people away.
比如：哦，他们尽力了；或者：事情没那么糟；或者：我长得挺好的；或者：哦，别人的情况要糟得多。也许所有这些都是真的，但如果你仍然在加班加点地为你的痛苦找借口，这是否意味着你真的没事？如果你仍然在以一种非常不被看见的方式、以其他人没有在挣扎的方式苦苦挣扎，我认为这真的是开始承认的时候了：嘿，也许我并不好。也许这种过度独立、过度坚韧、在情感上封闭自己的保护方式已经不再保护我了。当我们说出诸如“哦，你知道，他们只是尽力了，事情没那么糟，不管怎样”之类的话时，这其实只是我们在试图让自己的经历变得合理，并为原因给我们自己一个解释。
You start unnecessary fights and without even knowing why. And the why is that all along, you really don't understand what it means to be seen. And so being seen by someone feels very threatening. Because you have these parents who are like, you don't want to be seen. That's great for us. Let us be seen. We'll take up all the space. We'll take up all the oxygen in the room.
你知道，作为人类，我们渴望确定性，我们渴望答案。因此，我们陷入了这种幻想式的思考。我们执着于我们希望拥有的父母的形象，而不是我们实际拥有的父母，这一切都只是因为我们在想：好吧，如果他们没有正确对待我，如果他们不能成为我需要的父母，那也许是我的错？我认为这也与“足够好的童年”这个概念紧密相连，对吧？你知道，事情并非那么糟糕。他们不一定是虐待狂或缺席的。
You can just sit in the corner and not make a fuss and not make a sound while we throw insults at you or we throw problems at you or we are making you walk on eggshells. And so when you become an adult and you're like, ha, people actually expect me to talk about my feelings. People actually want to know things about me. It can feel very unnerving. The psychoanalyst Eric Erickson, he actually describes this phase of life.
我们每隔几年就会去度假。但情感忽视可能会带来深刻的创伤，即使你基本的需求得到了满足。你必须记住，小孩子们需要的不仅仅是食物和水。他们需要认可，他们需要安全感，他们需要爱，他们需要同理心。你需要这些，你理应得到这些。而为那个你没有得到的父母感到悲伤，这意义重大。这很痛苦。悲伤不仅仅关于死亡。
It's called intimacy versus isolation. And every single one of us does go through it. But people who had emotionally immature parents or early relationships will find that it's so much more. difficult because their blueprint for love and for closeness and for trust was shaped by someone who didn't understand any of those things. So yes, everyone's going to struggle with this and relationships are hard, but it's like you're stepping into intimacy and you feel ready for it and then you realize that you are trying to build a house on uneven foundations. You know,
它关乎任何形式的失去。当你终于接受了你的父母无法成为你所需要的那种人这个事实时，确实有一种真实的失落感。你为那个从未被允许的独立性感到悲伤。你为你那么渴望的关注感到悲伤。你为那种缺乏一致性感到悲伤。而且，由于没有重来的机会，这种感觉更加复杂了。
everyone else is putting up their house and it's a flawless production line and you're like, wait, I didn't know that the wood was rotten and I didn't know that the structure was shaky and I need to go and do all this extra work while everyone else is having an easy time and it can feel really freaking frustrating, honestly, because you crave closeness, but you simultaneously fear it or reject it before it has a chance to reject you. It is often at this stage that we kind of start to realize like, hey, perhaps my early environment wasn't what it should have been. And the issue really becomes it and the pain comes from trying to fill in the gaps ourselves and we try and find reasons to explain our parents' behavior or to dampen how difficult we found it at times by saying
你无法重塑你的童年。有时你会意识到：嗯，我无法改变这些人。我一直以为，如果我能让他们看到他们做了什么，为什么那是错的，以及为什么他们需要改变，我就会感觉好点。所有这些伤口都会被治愈。你最终会意识到：那只是一种替代品。他们现在的改变，是的，那会很好，但它无法解决以前发生的事情。也许我太执着于让这段关系按照我想要的方式运作了，以至于我没有意识到，也许这段关系实际上根本没有那么具有建设性。
things like oh they did their best or it wasn't that bad or I turned out fine or oh people have it way way worse and maybe all of that is true but if you're still working over time to explain away your pain does that mean that you are really okay if you are still struggling in very unseen ways in ways that other people are not struggling, I think it's really time to start to acknowledge, like, hey, maybe I'm not all right. Maybe being this hyper-independent, hyper-resilient, emotionally closed-off person isn't protecting me anymore. When we say things like, oh, you know, they just did their best, it wasn't that bad, whatever it is, this is really just us trying to make our experiences make sense and to give ourselves an explanation for why.
我总是对我的朋友们这样说：仅仅因为某人尽力了，并不意味着你本不应该得到更好的对待。你理应受到对待的标准，并不取决于另一个人满足该标准的能力。这就把我们带到了下一个重大问题。我们如何脱离？我们如何为自己找到某种内心的平静？既然我们知道：A，我们无法抹去过去；B，这些人可能是我们永远无法改变的。
You know, as humans, we want certainty, we want answers. And so we engage in this kind of fantasy thinking. We cling to the idea of the parent that we wish we had rather than the one that we actually do, all because we are like, well, if they didn't treat me right, if they couldn't be the parent I needed, was that maybe my fault? I think this really also closely links to this idea of the good enough childhood, right? You know, it wasn't all that bad. They weren't necessarily abusive or absent.
我们可能永远无法与他们建立我们想要的理想关系。所以我们真正关注的是脱离，是与父母保持距离去爱他们，而不必让他们像他们可能希望的那样成为你生活的中心。一旦你到了某个年龄，你确实有机会说：嘿，那不再是你的工作了。
We went on holidays every few years. But emotional neglect can be deeply wounding, even if your basic needs were met. You have to remember, children don't just need food and water. They need validation, they need safety, they need love, they need empathy. You needed that, you deserve that. And grieving the parent you didn't get, that's huge. That's painful. grief is not just about death.
我要在这里确立我的独立性。他们可能会反击，但你已经是个成年人了。你拥有技能和能力，可以重新定义并重新建立这段关系，基本上按照你自己的条件，并说：是的，在前18年、25年或不管多少年里，情况可能确实如此。但这并不意味着我现在不能将这段关系引导至其他方向。因此，为了脱离，首先要脱离这种关系的混乱，并将自己从他们创造的情感环境中抽离出来。
It's about any kind of loss. And there is a real sense of loss when you do come to terms with the fact that your parent couldn't be what you needed. You grieve the independence that was never allowed. You grieve the attention that you wanted so badly. You grieve the consistency. And then it's compounded by the fact that there's not a do-over.
首先，如果你有条件，找个办法在自己和父母之间留出一些物理空间，无论是搬出家门、去旅行，还是找一个远离你家乡或他们所在地的工作机会。有时，处理这类关系最好的方法就是空间，留出空间让你退出他们的控制轨道。当你不在他们的屋檐下、不遵守他们的规则时，你会注意到你感觉轻快了多少，你会注意到紧张感会
You can't redo your childhood. And sometimes you realize, well, I can't change these people. I keep thinking that if I could just make them see what they did and why that was wrong and why they need to change, I'll feel better. And all these wounds will be undone. And you realize eventually, like, that's just a proxy. Them changing now, yes, it would be great, but it wouldn't solve what happened before. And perhaps I'm too fixated on getting this relationship to work how I want it to. that I don't realize that maybe this relationship isn't actually that productive at all.
自然地消散，并且也会发现你的环境确实在塑造你的情绪，它塑造了你应对的能力，不仅是应对他们，还包括应对日常生活。所以，如果你想脱离，如果你想找到一种方法来治愈这些后果，我强烈建议慢慢制定一个离开的计划，离开这个环境，离开你的家庭住宅，停止生活在他们的屋檐下，在告诉他们之前把你的计划整理好。这样你就可以在某种程度上减少任何情感操纵的影响。你需要准备好说：我要搬出去了，我离开这里了，从今以后我们将这样继续沟通。如果这不是一个选项，你仍然可以做很多事情，在你的家庭之外建立社区
I always say this to my friends. Just because someone did their best doesn't mean you didn't deserve better. The standard for which you deserve to be treated is not determined by someone else's ability to meet the standard. And this really brings us to our next big question. How do we detach? How do we find some kind of peace for ourselves? knowing, A, we can't undo the past. B, these are people we may never be able to change.
那些你可以信任的人、你可以向他们抱怨的人，以及会认可这有时有多么糟糕的人，这也是无比宝贵的。如果你自己正艰难地接受他们的行为，第一步其实就是大声说出来并直接点名：我的父母在情感上是不成熟的，一个成熟的人不会这样做，我不配承受这些，父母的行为不该是这样的，我不想要这种关系。语言是非常非常具有解放性的。你知道，它真的能让你停止为自己所遭受的事情而自责，它能帮你停止试图通过过度表现或缩小自己来修复这段关系。其实这并不是关于指责。
We may never have the relationship with them that we wanted. So what we're really focusing on is detachment, is loving your parents from a distance without necessarily letting them be at the center of your lives, as they would probably like to be. Once you get to a certain age, you do have the opportunity to say, hey, that's not your job anymore.
这真正关乎的是清晰度。这关乎的是说：这就是发生的事情。这就是它塑造我的方式。也许我永远不会得到关于“为什么”的解释。也许他们永远不会承认。这并不能改变我的现实。接下来，我们要设定一些界限，而且不要带着罪恶感。界限，我需要大声而清楚地说出来，
I'm going to assert independence here. They may try and fight back, but you are an adult. You have the skills and the capabilities to redeterminate and re-establish this relationship on your own terms, basically, and say, yes, it may have been this for the first 18, 25, whatever, how many years. That doesn't mean that I can't now divert this relationship into something else. So in order to detach, firstly, from the chaos of this relationship, and in order to take yourself out of the emotional environment they have created.
不是为了主导，也不是强硬的。它们是一种尊重自我的标志和形式。它们并不意味着你对父母的爱减少了。它们意味着你足够爱自己，以保护你的情感健康。那么，在这些关系中，什么样的界限是绝对必不可少的呢？比如限制打电话的次数。当谈话变得有毒时转移话题。说：如果你想继续这样跟我说话，
Firstly, if you have the means, find a way to put some physical space between you and your parents, either by moving out of home, going traveling, finding a work opportunity that is away from your hometown or from where they're from, sometimes the best things for these kinds of relationships is just space, space to allow you to exit their orbit of control. When you're not in their home, by their rules, you will notice how much lighter you feel, you will notice how much tension
节日里我就不回家了。我不会去你家。设定一些你告诉他们是禁区的禁忌话题。我不想谈论政治。我不想谈论我姐姐在做什么。我不想谈论你和妈妈的关系。这至关重要。我真的希望你坐下来，然后说：好吧，到底是什么事情总是最终触发
naturally dissipates, and also how your environment really does shape your mood, and it shapes your ability to cope, not just with them, but with everyday life. So if you want to detach and if you want to find a way to heal the consequences of this for yourself, I would highly recommend slowly making a plan to exit, exit the environment, exit your family home, stop living under their roof, have your plan in order before telling them. That way you can kind of reduce the influence of any emotional manipulation. You need to be ready to be like, I'm moving out, I'm out of here, and this is how we're going to continue communicating from here and out. If that's an option, there are still so many things that you can do, building community outside of your family unit
我和父母之间可怕的谈话、争论或时刻？我只是，我们要避开这些。我们要避开它们，因为你可能已经尝试了足够多次让他们听进去，或者让你自己被听到，但你知道他们不会改变主意。现在这关乎你的内心的平静。一些其他的核心界限或你可以落实的事情包括：与他们的对话保持简短，不与他们分享私人的故事或细节，了解他们即将爆发、开始操纵你或解雇你的迹象，了解他们的这些触发点并表现得像
who you can trust and who you can complain to and who will validate how shit this is sometimes is also invaluable and if you're struggling to come to terms with their behavior yourself the first step is really just to say it out loud and to just name it my parents were emotionally immature a mature person wouldn't have done this i don't deserve that that's not how a parent should behave i don't want this kind of relationship language is very very liberating you know it really does allow you to stop blaming yourself for the things that you received it helps you to stop trying to fix the relationship by over functioning or shrinking yourself down. And it's actually not about pointing fingers.
...
It's really about clarity. It's about saying, this is what happened. This is how it shaped me. Maybe I'll never get an explanation as to why. Maybe they will never admit it. That does not change my reality. Next, we're going to be setting some boundaries without the guilt involved. Boundaries, and I need to say this loud and clear,
are not dominating, are not forceful. they are a sign and a form of self-respect. They do not mean you love your parent any less. They mean you love yourself enough to protect your emotional well-being. So what kind of boundaries are really essential in these relationships? Things like limiting phone calls. Changing the subject when conversations turn toxic. Saying if you want to continue to talk to me like this,
...
I won't be coming home for the holidays. I won't be coming around to your house. Having off-limit subject matter that you tell them is off-limit. I don't want to talk about politics. I don't want to talk about whatever my sister is doing. I don't want to talk about your relationship with mum. That is essential. I really want you to sit down and say, okay, what are the things that always end up triggering
terrible conversations and arguments or moments between me and my parents? I just, we're just going to avoid those. We're going to avoid them because you've probably tried enough times to make them listen or to make yourself heard that you know they're not. changing their mind. It's now about your peace. Some other things that are central boundaries or things that you can put in place is staying brief in your conversations with them, not sharing personal stories or details with them, knowing the signs that they are going to explode or going to start manipulating you or going to dismiss you, knowing those triggers for them and being like,
...
I'm actually going to opt out of this. Yeah, sorry. Like this is not. I'm not tolerating it. I'm walking away. Yes, you are going to get frustrated. Yes, you were probably going to get mad. That's actually not my fucking deal. That's not my problem. That's not my business.
其实我打算放弃这个了。是的，抱歉。就像这不是。我不会容忍这个的。我要走开。是的，你会感到沮丧。是的，你可能会生气。这其实不关我屁事。这不是我的问题。这不关我的事。
You're an adult. You choose how to emotionally regulate yourself, but you cannot co-regulate with someone who was angry and someone who doesn't know what they're doing. What do you need at this point to do better for yourself? What do you need at this point to feel better and less, less tense and less stressed. Remember, like, you are not responsible for your parents' feelings.
你是个成年人。你选择如何控制自己的情绪，但你不能和一个生气的人、一个不知道自己在做什么的人共同调节情绪。此时此刻，你需要什么来更好地对待自己？此时此刻，你需要什么来感觉更好、压力更小、更放松。记住，你不需要对父母的感受负责。
In fact, they are the adult. The level of responsibility, they're at the top. They are the ones who are meant to be creating a soft and a warm and a welcoming emotional environment for you. So if the tables have turned, the rulebook is now upside down. You can walk out. You can say, I don't want to be part of this. You are allowed to say, you're behaving very,
事实上，他们才是成年人。责任的层级，他们处于最高层。他们才是应该为你创造一个柔软、温暖和温馨的情感环境的人。所以，如果形势发生了逆转，规则手册现在就颠倒了。你可以走开。你可以说，我不想参与其中。你可以说，你的行为非常，
maturely. They're probably not going to acknowledge it, but you're allowed to say it out loud and be like, this is how I see these situations. This is how I see this happening. I'm going to validate the reality that I'm experiencing and I'm going to walk away. The hardest thing about boundaries is really just accepting that some people are never going to understand them. They're never going to agree. They're never going to like it. That doesn't make them wrong. It actually means they were probably necessary and that they are probably working. The easiest way to tell if a boundary is working, the easiest way to tell that one was needed is when you put up the boundary and someone is like a rabid dog bounding against it being like, what are you doing? I'm your parent. I don't deserve to be
成熟。他们可能不会承认，但你可以大声说出来，就像，我是这样看待这些情况的。我是这样看待这件事发生的。我要肯定我正在经历的现实，我要走开。界限最难的事情实际上只是接受有些人永远不会理解它们。他们永远不会同意。他们永远不会喜欢。这并不意味着他们是错的。这实际上意味着它们可能是必要的，而且它们可能正在发挥作用。判断界限是否起作用的最简单方法，判断是否需要界限的最简单方法是，当你设立界限时，有人就像疯狗一样在它周围跳跃，质问你在做什么？我是你的父母。我不配被
treated like this. You're so ungrateful. And it's like, huh, so a normal person, firstly I wouldn't have even needed to set this boundary. Secondly, they would have respected it if I did. The fact that they are so disturbed by the emotional consequences of their actions and your response to them proves that they're not normal and proves that you had the right reaction and you made the right decision. This is something I always say to people to help them understand this better. If you had a boss who treated you the way that your parents did, would you have quit by now? If you had a partner who treated you the way your parents do, you probably would have broken up with them at this point. If you had a friend who gave you the silent treatment, who didn't listen to your emotional requests, who ignored you unless they needed something, who dismissed you, who wouldn't let you share your feelings, would you be friends with them?
这样对待。你太不知感恩了。就像，哈，所以一个正常人，首先我甚至不需要设定这个界限。其次，如果我设定了，他们会尊重的。他们对自己的行为带来的情感后果以及你对他们的反应感到如此不安，这一事实证明他们不正常，并证明你有正确的反应，你做出了正确的决定。这是我经常对人们说的话，以帮助他们更好地理解这一点。如果你有一个老板，他对待你的方式和你的父母一样，你现在会辞职吗？如果你有一个伴侣，他对待你的方式和你的父母一样，你此时此刻可能已经和他分手了。如果你有一个朋友，他对你冷暴力，不听你的情感请求，除非有事才理你，对你不理不睬，不让你分享你的感受，你会和他们做朋友吗？
Would you have contact with them? No. So why do we make so many excuses for our parents when they should know better when, you know, I always think this, like, they decided to have you. And deciding to have a child, like they were opting into a responsibility that they are obviously struggling to fulfill, but they expect you to fulfill all the traditional ways that a child should behave. Like, it's a two-way straight. So the third way we're going to really attempt to detach here is by re-parent. parenting ourselves. You know, as we get older, we become the most important adult in our lives. Even if you have a partner, even if you have a really amazing friend, you are still the most important adult. You are still responsible for, I would say, 99% of your decisions. And so you also
你会和他们保持联系吗？不会。那么，为什么我们为父母找了那么多借口，而他们本该更懂事，你知道，我总是这样想，他们决定生下你。而决定生下一个孩子，就像他们选择了一项他们显然在努力履行却力不从心的责任，但他们期望你以传统孩子应有的所有方式来履行。这就像是一条双向街道。所以我们在这里真正尝试脱离的第三种方式是通过重新养育。我们自己。你知道，随着年龄的增长，我们成为生活中最重要的成年人。即使你有一个伴侣，即使你有一个非常棒的朋友，你依然是最重要的成年人。我要说的是，你仍然对你99%的决定负责。所以你也
have the capacity to take charge and to do what's best for yourself now, the way that a parent should have done for you when you were younger, the way that they should even be doing it for you now. The part of you, the childlike innocent part of you who was injured by their behavior still exists and they still deserve love even if it was in the past. Reparenting helps us heal that relationship with this past version of us and it helps us realize like, hey, it's not always going to be like this. There is an alternative. There is a way that I deserve to be treated and I'm going to firstly begin by emulating it myself. Now this might sound kind of. of intimidating at first, but reparenting really just means giving your adult self the grace
有能力掌控一切，做对你自己最好的事情，就像父母在你小时候应该为你做的那样，就像他们现在甚至应该为你做的那样。你内心深处那个被他们的行为伤害的、孩子气的、天真的部分依然存在，他们依然值得被爱，哪怕那是在过去。重新养育帮助我们治愈与过去自己的这种关系，它帮助我们意识到，嘿，事情并不总是这样的。还有另一种选择。我值得被这样对待，我首先要从自己开始模仿。这听起来可能有点。一开始可能会觉得有点吓人，但重新养育实际上只是意味着给予你成年的自己优雅
and the security that your childhood self-deserved. So encouraging yourself when doubt creeps in, even when it feels unnatural, holding yourself when you feel shame, allowing yourself to be playful, allowing yourself to be cringe, allowing yourself to be vulnerable. It could also be as simple as changing like your self-talk. So often, I just feel like we talk to ourselves so badly. We say, like, I'm so stupid. I'm a terrible person. I'm an idiot. A lot of those words, we didn't learn those ourselves. They were words that were said to us. And so replacing them and saying, I made a mistake and that's okay. I'm someone who was growing. I'm someone who was learning. That's essential because it's reprogramming.
以及你童年时自己应得的安全感。所以在怀疑潜入时鼓励自己，即使感觉很不自然，在感到羞耻时拥抱自己，允许自己嬉戏，允许自己犯尴尬，允许自己变得脆弱。这也可以像改变你的自我对话一样简单。很多时候，我觉得我们对自己说话太糟糕了。我们说，比如，我太蠢了。我是一个糟糕的人。我是个白痴。很多这些词，并不是我们自己学会的。那是别人对我们说的话。所以替换它们并说，我犯了一个错误，这没关系。我是一个在成长的人。我是一个在学习的人。这至关重要，因为这是在重新编程。
our internal dialogue and the voice of our inner critic so that it is more gentle and understanding. You know, if you could go back to when you were, let's say, five or 12 or 10 or 15, how would you wish your parents had responded to your emotional requests? How do you wish they had treated you? How do you wish they had loved you? emulate that. Imagine it. Deliver it back to yourself.
我们的内部对话和内心的批评者的声音，使其变得更加温和和理解。你知道，如果你能回到你五岁、十二岁、十岁或十五岁的时候，你希望你的父母对你的情感需求做出怎样的回应？你希望他们如何对待你？你希望他们如何爱你？去模仿它。想象一下。把它回馈给自己。
Reparenting is also about noticing what you're interested. need right now over what others may need from you. If you have emotionally immature parents, you are most likely used to being very focused on their needs. And that often ends up translating into other relationships as well. That's not your job. Your job right now is to say, what do I need in this situation? What do I need at this point in my life? What do I need during my day. What do I need in a relationship? And going out, going after it and delivering it to yourself. The decisions that your parents never made for you, you can now make them. You can now decide, hey, I'm going to emotionally respond this way. Hey, I'm going to have a nap at 2pm. Hey, I know that
重新养育也是关于注意到你感兴趣的内容。现在需要什么，而不是别人可能对你有什么需求。如果你有情绪不成熟的父母，你很可能习惯于非常关注他们的需求。这通常最终也会转化为其他关系。这不是你的工作。你现在的工作是说，在这种情况下我需要什么？在我人生的这个阶段我需要什么？我的一天中需要什么。我在一段关系中需要什么？然后走出去，去追求它并把它交给自己。你的父母从未为你做出的决定，你现在可以做出了。你现在可以决定，嘿，我要以这种方式做出情感回应。嘿，我打算在下午两点小睡一下。嘿，我知道
this relationship probably isn't right for me and I'm going to walk away because I have agency. and that's something that I think the children of emotionally immature parents often struggle with is this sense that like actually you are the boss and you are in charge and it's your life and it's your body and it's your emotions and your feelings and your reality. You can do what you want with that. You can make all of your choices from here on out. And no matter how much of a fuss they kick up, whatever it is that they want to say, it doesn't change anything.
这段感情可能不适合我，我要离开，因为我有自主权。我认为情绪不成熟的父母的孩子经常纠结的一点是这种感觉，即实际上你才是老板，你掌管一切，这是你的生活，你的身体，你的情绪，你的感觉和你的现实。你可以随心所欲。从现在开始你可以做出所有的选择。不管他们怎么大惊小怪，无论他们想说什么，都改变不了任何事。
They don't control you. You are allowed to rewire what love feels like and say, I actually deserve more or I don't deserve this. Okay, I'm getting very, you can say, I'm getting very passionate. So we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we're going to talk through some of our listener questions. You guys had so many questions for me about emotionally immature parents in your own lives, in your partner's lives, in so many different ways. There were so many questions and dilemmas that came up, so I'm excited to answer some of them. Stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
他们不能控制你。你可以重塑爱的感觉，并说，我其实值得拥有更多，或者我不配得到这个。好吧，我变得非常，你可以说，我变得非常情绪激动。所以我们要休息一下，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论一些听众的问题。你们对我提出了很多关于你们自己生活、伴侣生活中情绪不成熟的父母的问题，有各种各样的方式。有很多问题和困惑涌现出来，所以我很高兴能回答其中的一些问题。敬请期待。2%。这就是当还有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中。我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的.
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends...
收听《2%》。这就是在I-Hart电台上的T-W-O-P-P-Cent。苹果播客，或你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的女朋友……
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
哦天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-taped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
他会得到应得的惩罚。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上用双层胶带粘住小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什到底跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克古柯碱。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack. Yeah, yeah. Literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct.
澄清一下，84对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意聊聊快克。是的，是的。真的。但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论对错的第二集。
So I'm starting to see there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
所以我开始发现其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。现在你正在完成那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的一年之一。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。欢迎来到我的新播客。和我一起“学得艰难”，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了样东西。
And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
我们还在追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app.
绝对的。这是两个不同水平的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你的免费Our Heart Radio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So you guys all know that each week I go on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast if you want to follow and I tell you guys what I'm going to be talking about on this week's episode and I ask if you have any specific questions you want answered. For some episodes like this one, the topic is so broad and our experiences like they are so different that I might not fully cover what you want to know. Like I could do a six hour episode on this and still not touch on your unique specific. circumstance and so the listener questions are kind of the opportunity for me to touch on some of the more finer points. Let's start with question number one. What do you do when your parents
搜索《艰难学习》并立即收听。所以你们都知道，如果你们想关注的话，我每周都会在Instagram上的“那心理学播客”上发布消息，告诉你们我将在本周的节目中讨论什么，并询问你们是否有任何想要解答的具体问题。对于像这样的某些节目，主题太广泛了，我们的经历如此不同，以至于我可能无法完全涵盖你想知道的内容。就像我可以做一个六小时的节目，但仍然碰不到你独特具体的情况。所以听众的问题有点像我接触一些更精细要点的机会。让我们从第一个问题开始。当你的父母
put you in the middle of their fights? This was by far the most common question, especially for people whose parents are getting divorced as they become adults or who have seen this happen for years and years and years and are suddenly realizing like, hey, I'm the kid here. This actually shouldn't be my problem. This is a classic example of parentification. You have been put in the position of mediator, emotional regulator, diplomat. You are parenting your parents when your role is meant to be as their child. Let me say this. This is not okay behavior from your parents. You are not meant to be in the middle because you have a very different relationship with them, compared to the relationship that they have with each other.
把你卷入他们的争吵中时，你该怎么办？这是迄今为止最常见的问题，尤其是对于那些父母在他们成年时离婚的人，或者多年来一直看到这种情况发生并突然意识到，嘿，我是这里的孩子。这其实不应该是我的问题。这是父母职责幼体化的典型例子。你被放在了调解员、情绪调节器、外交官的位置上。你在扮演父母的父母，而你的角色本应是他们的孩子。让我这么说吧。你父母的这种行为是不对的。你不应该处在中间，因为你与他们的关系非常不同，相比于他们彼此之间的关系。
And also, you are not a couples counselor. You are not their best friend. You are not the person they can rant to. You are their child. There are different relationships, and we have different relationships with different people for a reason. Sometimes, though, the reason this happens is because, A, they have no one else to talk about it, too, in their personal life,
而且，你不是婚姻咨询师。你不是他们最好的朋友。你不是他们可以倾诉的人。你是他们的孩子。这是不同的关系，我们和不同的人建立不同的关系是有原因的。不过，有时发生这种情况是因为，A，他们在个人生活中没有其他人可以倾诉，
in which case they need to go and see a therapist. B, they feel like because you are so close to the situation, you can somehow be impartial, also incorrect. C, sometimes it's just an accidental slip-up or D. Your opinion is actually becoming the battleground for them because you are the product of both of these two people. So they may feel like, if I can win you over, if you agree with me, well, then this other person has to listen.
这种情况下，他们需要去看治疗师。B，他们觉得因为你对情况很了解，所以你某种程度上可以保持公正，这也是不对的。C，有时这只是一次偶然的失误，或者D。你的意见实际上正成为他们争夺的战场，因为你是这两个人的结晶。所以他们可能会觉得，如果我能赢得你，如果你同意我的观点，那么另一个人就必须听取意见。
You are the best weapon they could have in their arsenal, the opinion of the child that the person and them both raised together. So they win. If they get you to agree with them, they win. It's very inappropriate. It's also very uncomfortable. So I'm going to give you a sentence that you can use in these situations. That sounds really hard, but I'm not impartial here. And I really wish I could be, but it's just never going to happen. I really love mom slash dad, whoever it is, insert here, and I'm sure you value how much they love me and want me to stay close to both of you.
你是他们武器库中最好的武器，也就是他们两个共同抚养的孩子的意见。所以他们赢了。如果他们让你同意他们，他们就赢了。这非常不恰当。这也让人很不舒服。所以我将给你一个句子，你可以在这些情况下使用。听起来真的很难，但我在里头无法保持公正。我真的希望我能做到，但这永远不可能发生。我真的很爱妈妈斜杠爸爸，不管是谁，在此插入，我确信你也很珍视他们多么爱我，并希望我能和你们俩保持亲密。
So I can't be the person you vent to about that. I'm sorry. Short and simple. And if they argue, play to their empathy. Ask them, how would you feel if you found out that mom slash dad was having these same conversations with me about you? Would you want that? Probably not. Or play dumb when they say, oh, you know, he just always does this or she's just like this and this and this be like, oh, I'm, you know, I'm just a kid really, like, what would I know? Or, you know, I'm really young still. I don't really have much experience to know what you should do.
所以关于这个，我不能做你倾诉的对象。我很抱歉。就这么简单。如果他们反驳，就利用他们的同理心。问问他们，如果发现爸爸或者妈妈也这样向我抱怨你，你会有什么感受？你愿意这样吗？大概不会吧。或者装傻，当他们说，哦，你知道的，他总是这样，或者她就是这种人时，你就说，哦，你知道的，我其实只是个小孩，我能懂什么呢？或者，你知道的，我还很年轻。我真的没什么经验，不知道你该怎么做。
I don't really understand this. Reinforce subliminally. Like, hey, hello, reminder, I'm the child in this situation. And I find that really like helpful to just to be like almost give them a bit of a snap of the fingers a wave cup call like this isn't appropriate. You know it's inappropriate. We're going to move on. Hopefully that kind of helps. Second question. I'm dating someone with immature parents but they can't see it. How can I firstly cope with it but also help him to see that they have a problem?
我其实不太懂这个。潜移默化地强化这一点。比如，嘿，你好，提醒一下，我是这当中的孩子。我觉得这样真的很有用，就像是给他们打个响指、挥挥手，敲个警钟说：这并不合适。你知道这很不合适。我们要翻篇了。希望这多少有点帮助。第二个问题。我在和一个父母很不成熟的人约会，但他却看不出来。我该如何首先应付这种情况，同时又帮他认识到他们有问题呢？
This is a tough one. I think firstly you've got to realize that this is not something that you're going to be able to fix. This is not a relationship that you can take charge of. This has most likely existed way before you came along. You have to approach this really delicately. I always think about trying to tell your friend that you hate their partner. Nine out of ten times, they aren't going to see it the way that you do and they probably aren't going to listen. And then you're just going to become the enemy.
这个问题有点棘手。我觉得首先你得意识到，这不是你能解决的问题。这不是一段你可以掌控的关系。这种情况很可能在你出现之前就已经存在很久了。你必须非常小心地处理这件事。我总是会想到，当你试图告诉一个朋友你讨厌他们的伴侣时。十有八九，他们不会像你那样看待问题，而且他们可能根本听不进去。然后你就会变成他们的敌人。
So please just remember as much as you want them to be happy and at peace and you want their life to be free of stress and tension. It's not your job to fix their parents' relationship. It's also not your job to make them see it and have to fix it either. You just want to try and slowly introduce the idea to them in a subtle way. So instead of being like your parents are so immature, try something like, hey, have you ever noticed like this thing? How interesting. Oh, how did you feel about that when they just did what they did just now, when they shut you down? Oh, have you ever noticed that you kind of have to parent your parents emotionally?
所以请记住，不管你多么希望他们快乐、平静，多么希望他们的生活没有压力和紧张。修复他们父母的关系不是你的工作。让他们看清现实并加以解决也不是你的工作。你只需要尝试以微妙的方式慢慢向他们引入这个想法。所以，不要说“你的父母太不成熟了”，而是试着说，“嘿，你有没有注意到类似这样的事情？真有意思。哦，刚才他们那样对你、冷落你的时候，你有什么感觉？”或者“你有没有发现，你有时得在情感上去照顾你的父母？”
Oh, is that something that's been going on for a while? Like, oh, explain where that came from. I want to know more about what it was like in your childhood. Like, these are very non-judgmental openings that let them discover patterns on their own. And I really want you to remember, like, your role is to listen. Your role is to really just facilitate them figuring it out for themselves and just to be open to that not always being linear. You know, they're not always going to be totally awake and open eyeed to the fact that their parents have some serious issues. Like from the moment that you start introducing the idea and it might take them some time and there might be excuses.
哦，这种情况持续有一段时间了吗？比如，哦，说说这是怎么回事吧。我想多了解一下你小时候是什么样的。这些都是非常不带评判色彩的切入点，能让他们自己发现一些模式。我真的希望你记住，你的角色是倾听。你的角色实际上就是协助他们自己把事情理清楚，并且要接受这个过程不一定是一帆风顺的。你知道的，他们不会随时都完全清醒地意识到自己的父母存在严重的问题。从你开始引入这个概念的那一刻起，可能需要他们花点时间，而且他们可能会找各种借口。
But remember, you don't have to be around his family if you don't want to be. if it comes up, that's when you can discuss it. But this is going to sound controversial. Like, if this is someone you consider one day marrying, you're marrying their family as well. So if it does get to the point where you have said something because it involves you and they're like, nope, it's not like that. They're denying it.
但请记住，如果你不想的话，你不必和他的家人待在一起。如果聊到这个，那你们就可以讨论。但接下来这话可能会有点争议。如果这是你考虑将来要结婚的人，你其实也是在和他的家庭结婚。所以，如果事情发展到这个地步——因为这关系到你，你说了出来，而他们却说：“不，根本不是这样的”，他们在否认。
They're not seeing it. Really think about how that's going to end up in their relationship with you. You know, as we said, or with your children. Like, as I said before, some people end up being very emotionally aware and very hyper-independent and very, they're able to kind of interrupt the pattern of generational, generational, emotional immaturity. Other people aren't. And the people who aren't are the ones who don't even recognize it to begin with.
他们没有看清现实。好好想想这最终会如何影响他们与你的关系。你知道的，正如我们所说，或者与你们孩子的关系。就像我刚才说的，有些人最终会有很高的情商，非常极度的独立，并且能够打破代际之间情感不成熟的恶性循环。其他人则做不到。而做不到的人，正是那些从一开始就认不清现实的人。
So not to make this a very serious conversation, but at some point, you may have to wonder, or ask yourself, if he can't recognize this in them, what if one day that's us and he can't recognize it in himself? All right. Question number three. How do not become like them? This is another really big question. I think firstly, you're listening to this episode,
所以，并不是要把这弄成一次多么严肃的对话，但在某种程度上，你可能不得不去思考或问自己：如果他在他们身上都认不清这一点，万一有一天这种情况发生在我们身上，而他在自己身上也认不清呢？好的。第三个问题。如何不变成他们那样？这也是一个非常大的问题。我想首先，你在听这一期节目，
the fact that you're listening to this, that you're curious, reflective, open, that matters. You've basically already done, I would say, 75% of the work, which is just acknowledgement. The next step is just to sometimes really hold yourself accountable to the point of discomfort. And what I mean by that is you do genuinely have to be like, hey, the behavior that I'm exhibiting is not on and it is reflective
你正在听这个，你充满好奇、懂得反思、思想开放，这很关键。我想说，你基本上已经完成了75%的工作，那就是承认问题的存在。接下来的步骤就是，有时候要真正对自己负责，甚至负责到让你感到不舒服的地步。我的意思是，你确实必须坦然面对：嘿，我表现出来的这种行为是不行的，它反映了
or it is reminiscent of how my parents have perhaps related to me. I don't want to be that person. The ball stops here. Try and focus on some more positive examples. Who are people in your life who emulate emotional maturity? Who are people who communicate openly? look at their relationships and realize like, I actually, this is very, very healthy and, you know, them just being open about their feelings has not destroyed their connection.
或者它让人想起了我的父母过去对待我的方式。我不想成为那样的人。到此为止，绝不让这种代际循环继续下去。试着关注一些更积极的榜样。你生活中有哪些人展现出了成熟的情感？有哪些人能够敞开心扉进行沟通？看看他们的关系，然后意识到，其实这非常非常健康，而且，你知道的，他们坦诚表达自己的感受并没有破坏彼此的联系。
Huh, that might be a possibility for me. I found that I have a couple friends who are just so emotionally mature and I'm constantly just like so impressed by their ability to handle their emotions and the emotions of others and it makes me want to be a better person. Think about what your parents were into in a situation and do the, opposite. Sometimes that is just like the easiest way to not become like them. And therapy, like, there is so much that a therapist could help you see that I could never help you see because I don't really know you, but also that you're just doing your own work and just trying to
哈，这对我来说可能也是一种可能。我发现我有几个朋友，他们情商真的太高了，我总是对他们处理自己情绪以及他人情绪的能力佩服得五体投地，这让我想要成为一个更好的人。想想你父母在某种情况下会怎么做，然后反着来。有时候这简直就是不变成他们那样的最简单的方法。还有心理咨询，治疗师能帮你看到很多你自己永远看不到的东西，因为我不真的了解你，而且如果你只是自己做功课、试图
solve it yourself. There's no mirror. Like, you need someone sometimes to hold up a mirror to yourself and say, hey, look where the shadow's falling here. Have you noticed this about yourself? It's super essential therapy for this kind of thing. Top notch. Okay, our fourth question, and I'll be honest, me and my partner spent like an hour talking about this question last night, what do you do
自己解决问题。身边是没有镜子的。有时候你需要有人为你举一面镜子，对你说：“嘿，看看阴影落在了哪里。你有没有注意到自己身上有这一点？”对于这类事情，心理咨询是至关重要的。顶级的帮助。好的，我们的第四个问题，说实话，我和我的伴侣昨晚花了大约一个小时来讨论这个问题：当你希望某个
when you want one parent in your life but not the other? I will say I thought about it for a while. The only specific advice I could come up with is to talk to the parent you do want in your life about it, see what they think. You know,
父母留在你的生活中，而另一个不用时，你该怎么办？我得说，我想了很久。我能想到的唯一具体建议是，和你希望留在生活中的那个父母谈谈这件事，看看他们的想法。你知道的，
they understand your other parent, not just as a parent, but as a partner as well. And I'm always surprised, like, of course, my parents know so much more about each other than I do because they have this whole different relationship. So invite the parent you want in your life into your thinking and just see how they respond and see if they have any way of approaching it. I also want to really recommend a podcast episode that talked about this in such an anecdotal, personal empathetic, wonderful way. And it's from this American life, it's episode 823, The Question Trap. And in that podcast episode, they talk to a family of two kids, mom and dad, one of the kids
他们不仅把你的另一个父母看作父母，也把对方看作伴侣。我总是很惊讶，当然啦，我的父母对彼此的了解远多于我对他们的了解，因为他们有着完全不同的关系。所以，把你希望留在生活中的那位父母纳入你的思考范围，看看他们作何反应，看他们有没有什么应对的方法。我还想强烈推荐一期播客节目，它以一种极其真实、个人化、充满同理心且美妙的方式探讨了这个话题。那是来自《美国生活》（This American Life）的第823期节目，名叫《问题陷阱》（The Question Trap）。在那期播客中，他们采访了一个家庭，家里有两个孩子、爸爸妈妈，其中一个孩子
is openly gay. And the father is becoming increasingly right wing and he's anti-vax. And he's having real, I don't want to say difficulties. He's basically just not. accepting of his child's you know I hate to say lifestyle but his child's identity like at all and him and the mom are still together and the mother is just this wonderful warm kind person and obviously the children want to be friends with their mother and what they want to be still in each other's lives but not with the father and the way they handle it is so complex and nuanced and interesting and so although I don't have specific detailed advice on this, listen to that podcast episode. I think it will just make you feel a lot
公开出柜了。而父亲的右翼倾向越来越严重，他还是个反疫苗主义者。他遇到了真正的——我不想说是困难。他基本上就是不接受他孩子的，你知道的，我讨厌这么说，但就是不接受他孩子的身份，完全不接受。而他和妈妈依然在一起，母亲是一个非常美妙、温暖、善良的人，孩子们显然想和母亲做朋友，他们希望彼此的生活中依然有母亲的存在，但不想有父亲。他们处理这件事的方式如此复杂、细腻且有趣，所以，虽然我没有给出具体详细的建议，但去听听那期播客节目吧。我想它会让你觉得
less alone and yeah, it really got me thinking. Final question, how do I teach my parents' basic emotional literacy, regulation and communication? You can't. I don't think you can. I'm sorry. I think that if they wanted to do it, there are resources. and at the age you are and at the age they are, I'm sure they have encountered issues with their emotional immaturity before and it really hasn't called them to change. What I'm saying is not that they can't change, but that it's not your job to convince them or to teach them.
不那么孤单，而且是的，它确实让我陷入了深思。最后一个问题，我该如何教导我的父母掌握基本的读懂情绪能力、情绪调节与沟通技巧？你做不到。我觉得你做不到。我很抱歉。我认为，如果他们想这么做的话，是有很多资源的。以你现在的年龄和他们现在的年龄，我确信他们以前也遇到过因情感不成熟而产生的问题，但这并没有促使他们改变。我想说的是，并不是他们不能改变，而是说去说服他们或教导他们不是你的工作。
What I'm saying is that they have every reason to want to change already if you've already brought it up with them, if you've already talked about it with them, trying to therefore teach them, like they should already be open to that. And if they're not, I don't think it's your job and I don't think you'll be that successful. What we're really aiming for here is that their behaviours don't get passed along, that you are okay, that you feel safe in your other relationships, and that you have proper boundaries with them so that their poor emotional regulation doesn't translate into your emotional tension and distress.
我想说的是，如果你已经向他们提起过这件事，如果你已经和他们讨论过这件事，他们其实已经有充足的理由想要去改变了。因此再去试图教导他们——他们本该已经对此保持开放态度了。如果他们没有，我觉得这不是你的工作，而且你也不会取得多大成功。我们在这里真正要达到的目标是：他们的行为不会传给下一代，你能够过得很好，你在其他关系中感到安全，并且你与他们保持适当的界限，这样他们糟糕的情绪调节就不会转化为你的精神紧张和痛苦。
And I'm sure people will disagree with me on this. And maybe one day I'll also disagree with myself and I will change my mind and I will let you know if I do. But from everything that I was reading and all the research, I just think that if someone doesn't want to change, they will not change. If someone doesn't want to learn. if someone has been given multiple opportunities to learn and they have not done so, it's not your issue. And I just think it's yet another way that they are preemptifying you. Remember, they were
我确信人们在这个问题上会不赞同我。也许有一天我也会不赞同我自己，我会改变我的想法，如果我改变了，我会让你知道。但根据我阅读的所有内容以及所有的研究，我只是觉得，如果一个人不想改变，他是不会改变的。如果一个人不想学习，如果已经给了某人多次学习的机会，而他们却没有这样做，那这就不是你的问题。而且我只是觉得，这是他们对你进行过早成年化（父母化）的又一种方式。记住，他们
meant to teach you these things. That was your role as a child. And so the fact that you feel like you need to teach them is just further evidence of their parentification of you. And I think engaging in this kind of thinking of like, I'm going to change. them and I can help them is actually just further involving you in the stress and the drama and the discomfort of feeling like their parent and not the other way around. I am totally open to feedback on that. So if someone has had an experience in doing this, please let me know your tips or your tips for any of these issues, for just handling this yourself. If you are someone who has gone through this, who is going through this as we all end up.
本来应该教导你这些事情。那是你作为孩子的角色。所以，当你觉得你需要去教导他们时，这恰恰进一步证明了他们将你父母化了。而且我认为，沉浸在“我要改变他们、我能帮助他们”这种想法中，实际上只是让你进一步卷入了那种感觉自己像他们的父母、而不是反过来的压力、戏剧性和不适感之中。我完全愿意接受对此事的反馈。所以，如果有人在这方面有过经验，请告诉我你的建议，或者针对这些问题中任何一点的建议，如何自己处理这些事情。如果你是经历过这一切的人，或者像我们最终都会经历的那样，正在经历这一切的人，
I feel like there is no end point to going through this. What have you done to help yourself? What have you done to manage this? What have you done to put up boundaries? I want to know. Leave some suggestions in the comments for others who are dealing with this. Also as a reminder that you are not alone. Emotional immaturity from previous generations,
我觉得经历这一切是没有终点的。你做了什么来帮助自己？你做了什么来应对这一切？你做了什么来设定界限？我想知道。在评论区留下一些建议，给其他正在经历这些的人。同时也提醒大家，你并不孤单。前几代人带来的情感不成熟，
it's now on a decline, but we're still dealing with the remnants of a very suppressed, stagnant, closed-off society. and it's really freaking tough. And it's so tough when you're looking at your parent just being like, be an adult for once. Be my fucking parent. That's your job. Not my job. Be mature and they just can't do it.
现在正在走向衰退，但我们仍然在处理一个曾经极度压抑、停滞不前、封闭的社会的残余影响。这真的太难了。当你看着自己的父母，心里想着“拜托像个成年人一次吧。做我该死的父母吧。那是你的工作，不是我的工作。成熟一点吧”，而他们却偏偏做不到时，这种感觉太难受了。
So I have a lot of love for you. You deserve to be seen, valued, cared for. You deserve to have them help you regulate rather than the other way around. But I promise you there are relationships out there where you won't have to do this continuously where there is a healthy emotional framework and emotional relationship waiting for you so I hope you find it and no you're not alone in this. If you enjoyed this episode, send it to someone who you think may also benefit from it. Share it online, share it on Instagram.
所以我对你们充满爱。你值得被看见、被重视、被关怀。你值得让他们来帮你调节情绪，而不是反过来。但我向你保证，生活中总会有这样的关系：你不需要不断地去做这些事，那里有健康的的情感框架和情感关系在等着你，所以我希望你能找到它。不，在这条路上你并不孤单。如果你喜欢这期节目，把它转发给你认为也可能从中受益的人。在网上分享，在Instagram上分享。
I love seeing where you guys are listening. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology podcast so you can be involved in future episodes, listener questions or just know. When episodes go live, make sure to buy my book if you feel called to do so, called Person in Progress. It's been out for exactly a month and I'm still in shock by that fact, but the response has just been so beautiful. And I can't get into it because I'll get emotional. But thank you, thank you, thank you. And until next time, stay safe, be kind.
我喜欢看你们都在哪里收听。确保你在Instagram上关注我：@That Psychology podcast，这样你就能参与到以后的节目、听众提问中，或者及时了解节目何时上线。如果你觉得有召唤的话，一定要买我的书，书名叫《成长中的人》（Person in Progress）。这本书出版正好一个月了，对此我至今仍感到震惊，但大家的反馈实在是太美妙了。我不能说太多，否则我会情绪激动。但谢谢你们，谢谢，谢谢。下次见之前，保重，保持善良。
Make sure you're following along. Be gentle with yourself and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stage. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
确保你一直在关注。对自己温柔一点，我们很快很快就会聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度背后的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
身体素质，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是I-HeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。
on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it
在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻，84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay），我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每期节目我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的，
With our friends, fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people Listen to Look Back at it On the IHeart Radio app
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《Look Back at it》，
Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
苹果播客，或者任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《用惨痛方式学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《用惨痛方式学到的教训》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。百分百真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。